[Música]
[Aplausos]
don aurelio es un señor que realmente me
parecía el señor más curioso del mundo
era como de este tamaño y morenito lo
que más curioso este señor es que
llevaba días y días y días y días hay
agachado frente a su mesa yo todas las
tardes iba para visitarlo y don aurelio
me miraba con una cara de esas caras
serenas que guardan secretos me miraba y
me decía un poco más yo lo miraba y
decía don don aurelio que está haciendo
y don aurelio se giraba lentamente me
decía algo habían pasado como dos
semanas cuando voy a la casa de don
aurelio y don aurelio se giró me dice
acabe yo lo miro entrenador yo tenía la
mesita
un pequeño arete chiquitito haciendo
cosa muy chiquita muy pequeñita yo le
dije ay pero don aurelio se tardó tanto
tiempo para hacer éxito y donde ábrelo
me dijo algo que tal vez después en el
camino entendería es que me dice lo que
pase dijo es que estas cositas
chiquitita tan pequeñita que acabo de
hacer me tomó tanto tiempo porque le
puse cada detalle cada segundo cada
momento entonces me acerqué para ver
quién es a éste una cosa tan pequeñita
era una cholita una cholita con aretes y
segunda vez con aretes
con sobre edito compañerita con las
trenzas una cosa que realmente le había
costado hacer durante tanto tiempo
yo le dije don aurelio pero a final de
cuentas para qué hizo eso y él me dijo
para regalárselo a alguien
en ese momento realmente no lo entendí
mucho tiempo después me enteré que fue
un regalo para su hija y la hija hasta
el día de hoy si algún día tiene la
suerte de conocerla a ella pues
descubrirán que realmente es arete ese
reto es un regalo más allá de
simplemente el hecho de un arete
chiquito de plata es un regalo de tiempo
es un regalo del corazón es un regalo de
amor
mi nombre es david ciudad gonzález soy
narrador de cuentos soy cuentacuentos de
hace nueve años voy contando cuentos por
diferentes lugares del mundo he tenido
la suerte de participar en diferentes
festivales tanto acá como en otros
países he aprendido en este caminar a
contar historias a escribir historias a
escuchar
y sigo aprendiendo porque aunque no lo
crean contar cuentos también pues llevo
se procede soy un buen tiempo y demás
cosas
hace mucho tiempo todas las experiencias
más lindas en mi vida de cuentacuentos
tal vez de las que terminan marcando
cierta parte de mi camino
estaba estaba yo pues haciendo lo que
normalmente me gusta hacer estaba
sentado en mi casa pensando en un montón
de cosas entonces mira un amigo me dice
que teníamos trabajo que tenemos una
función me voy corriendo hasta ese
teatro y en ese teatro pues me siento y
empiezo a contar una bueno la primera
historia no cuenta el cuento no sé que
estoy contra no de contar la historia y
cuando termino estoy cansado y ximo
porque los que hacen teatro hacen música
o algo artístico sabes cuando acaba una
función uno termina con las energías muy
pero muy muy muy abajo
los que han visto en cuentacuentos y han
tenido la suerte vieron cuentacuentos
saben con una función puede durar dos
minutos cinco minutos una hora
pero lo que muchas veces se nos va es el
hecho de que esa presentación de 25 una
hora lleva pues un proceso de semanas de
meses de una preparación constante
constante de conocer la historia hasta
que uno pueda conocerla tan bien que
pueda fluir a través del mundo de las
palabras que puedan fluir y hacer que la
gente que está escuchando pueda
interiorizarse y viajar
sumando todas esas horas esos meses se
hacen pues meses años se hace un camino
casi casi casi infinito
cuando acabes a esa función está así
super super cansada entonces me voy
hacia el auditorio para saludar a la
gente y organizar un poquito porque uno
de artista también le toca hacer eso
estaba organizando un poco el aula bueno
el espacio el teatro con repente una de
las compañeras de las chicas que ha
visto la función se me acerca me
presenté y empezamos a conversar y entre
tanta conversación que tenemos me dice
que había tardado dos horas en llegar
hasta el teatro yo le digo dos horas dos
horas para ver para venir acá y ver un
espectáculo de cuentos y me dice que si
yo digo entonces y ahorita que te vas a
tu casa tardarás las mismas dos horas y
ella hace un pequeño silencio sonríe y
me dice que tal vez más
entonces la miro y en mi cabeza empieza
a imaginar la imaginas en su casa en su
cuarto alistándose de un lado por el
otro buscando el celular buscando las
llaves usted no toda la cartera
metiéndole todo en la mochila y así
saliendo corriendo de su casa se va
corriendo hasta la parada del bus se
detiene ahí esperaba hacer esa fila
interminable que puesto que hacer a la
hora pico está ahí esperando esperando
de repente sube le toca estar parada
porque realmente a las horas pico no
tiene que estar parado se agarra del
fierro ese y está ahí esperando
esperando y baje y viaja dos horas a las
dos horas llega el teatro comprar su
entrada hace otra vez la fila se mete
de la función y en este momento estoy
hablando con ella fueron dos horas más
una hora fueron tres horas que ella
invirtió más dos horas que le va a
costar volver a su casa fueron cinco
horas que esta chica que andrea invirtió
para llegar a ver una función
entonces me pongo a pensar y me pongo a
ver al resto de la gente que está
todavía en el teatro y me pongo a pensar
cuántas horas invirtió todo cada una de
estas personas en llegar hasta este
momento para ver esta función
ahora pues uno diría y sobre una
pregunta qué bueno pero si la gente
invierte tanto tiempo pues uno invierte
más tiempo en prepararse un segmento de
la universidad uno viaja uno paga
talleres hace un montón de cosas pues
para estar listos para estar listos para
ese momento preciso que uno tenga que
subirse al escenario y pues presentarse
eso es cierto pero creo que la respuesta
va en que nosotros elegimos eso yo como
cuentacuentos elegí contar cuentos elegí
prepararme para contar historias yo lo
elegí
e invertir mi tiempo en esto porque es
cierto que donde donde invertimos el
tiempo invertimos el corazón
pero el público
el público que viene a ver una función
ustedes que están acá ustedes que están
allá ustedes invirtieron el tiempo
porque ustedes eligieron estar acá
porque ustedes eligieron creer no sólo
en el trabajo de ese artista de esa
persona que ese teatro de ese músico de
ese pintor
porque el público elige al artista
reconociendo su talento reconociendo su
preparación reconociendo que has
invertido tanto de tu corazón en eso que
te apasiona
una de las cosas que muchos artistas han
aprendido con el paso del tiempo ya
otras cosas que con el paso del tiempo
también a uno se lo olvida es eso porque
cuando acaba una función y pues uno
siente que el público está medio raro
medio extraño y uno pues dice es que el
público está muy mal o si el público
está raro está desanimado pero no al
final de cuentas el público ya cumplió
el público invirtió su tiempo invirtió
dinero invirtió pensamiento en el
transcurso de la semana para elegir
estar ahí porque especialmente uno
podría elegir ir a otro teatro y la otra
presentación ir a otro concierto elegir
otro restaurante elegir otro profesional
pero te eligen a ti
me eligieron a mí
en el teatro siguió conversando con
andrea estamos charlando charlando y me
dice el coordinador que la función está
por empezar la siguiente función
le agradezco juntos del corazón el
asiento no voy a la parte de atrás
estaba cansado
el coordinador me dice que bien 120
personas ahí
me pongo a pensar en lo que andrea me
había enseñado hace un momento en que
cada una seis personas ha invertido
tiempo para estar acá
dejo que el cansancio se me vaya yendo
pienso que realmente todo lo que he
hecho todo el tiempo que ha invertido
para esto para contar historias tiene
que ser algo tengo que entregárselo a
esa gente que está acá porque las
personas del público y están a kaymer ha
regalado me ha regalado su tiempo me
arreglan su tiempo con el corazón yo lo
que tengo que hacer en este momento es
dejar dejar que ese cansancio que es ese
excusas que a veces que uno se pone se
vayan yendo
se abre el telón salvo
en medio de la gente reconozco andrea
ella está sonriendo y yo sonrío todo el
público me siento feliz
entonces empieza a contar
y mientras voy contando para mis
adentros voy pensando en un don aurelio
y recuerdo que ahora don aurelio tenía
razón que cuando alguien te regala su
tiempo con el corazón un artista una
persona que cree en lo que hace tiene
que también entregarse a su público
regalar a ese tiempo esas cosas que es
experimentado que ha prendido esas cosas
que los marcaron el camino traer hasta
este momento y entregárselos a la gente
y regalárselas con todo el corazón
[Aplausos]